you do the crime you do the time that's
how the saying goes isn't it
I ask because nowadays I feel more and
more that the same should be amended to
you do the crime but I don't worry about
it that was reinforced for me this week
when the prison Minister Rory Stuart's
announced that he's considering banning
sentences of less than six months mr.
Stewart feels such sentences are long
enough to damage criminals but not long
enough to heal him what he argue is that
in such cases community sentences are
more effective in both rehabilitation
and to reduce reoffending he also hopes
by implementing this plan he will reduce
strain on our stretched Prison services
mr. Stewart's
have got some news for you if your
prison services are stretched fund them
properly and whilst I am indeed a fan of
rehabilitation it should surely only go
hand-in-hand with punishment - well
supposing I won't agree with you I mean
if I remember making a programme I mean
I've been to a lot of Prisons I'm never
making a program around business 3040
years ago and they said if we if the
prison populations gets to 40,000 we're
going to be in crisis well it's now
85,000 we're sending more and more and
more people to prison and that some such
and more as Stewart who is I think it's
a prison ministers Qui brave man who
says if I can't solve lots of these
things in the year I'll give up the job
I think he's doing a it's an interesting
thing that he's doing what we might do
better is that they've already done it
in Scotland and it might be interesting
to see what the results are in Scotland
but I think the evidence is pretty clear
that if you send people to prison for
the first time it's it's an enormous
shock but in the end they become
institutionalized and they become part
of it and if you can stop that and use
community services instead I think
that's quite a good idea but the other
big thing is every person we've said to
prison cost us thirty thousand pounds
someone on a community service cost five
and I think I think we've become
obsessed about sending people to prison
I think politicians and that's why I
admire mr. Schurr politicians
historically particularly labor
politicians in a tough on crime tough on
the causes of crime meant that we we
just carried on sending people to prison
when we didn't see any evidence that it
would have an impact I was just gonna
say great what's the role of prison is
it protection rehabilitation or
punishment well everyone would say it's
a bit of each but actually where's the
punishment if they don't even go to jail
well it is these are people aren't quite
low sentences and what they're saying is
if it's good if it's quite low since
let's try rehabilitation okay but listen
with every crime there is a victim so
even if it's not a violent crime even if
it's a burglary or a car theft or
someone gives you a bit of a smack on
the street okay the victim has to know
that we have a criminal justice system
that cares more about them than the
people who try to wreck their lives and
Rory Stewart who I actually like and
admire actually you know he talks about
the six-month sentencing like it like
it's a it's a form as a form of
counselling like a some form of therapy
not a punishment people need to know
that the the people who hurt them are
going to be punished and the community
sentencing I would totally agree with if
it worked it doesn't work
judges and magistrates are entirely no
they don't work
they've entirely lost faith in them just
say first of all to clarify this
proposed reform it doesn't include
violent offenses north central offenses
and it's only for offenses that are less
than 12 months so things like you know
pickpocketing or stealing from a store
and usually what happens when you take a
17 16 14 year old even for juvenile
offenses if you put them in prison for
the first time Gregg's point kicks in
they learn hardened from hardened
criminals they learn how to be better at
crime they become brutalize they could
end up joining gangs many of them do and
the evidence indicates that they come
out and reoffended so it isn't the best
way to protect the magic community
coming out coming out to commit more and
more quite imogene 30 percent let me
just say this fact 35 percent of the
people who go to
have been given at least five comunist
community service orders and set before
they go so in Scotland is that they are
trying this in Scotland but the
community service option for sentence is
less than 12 years is currently optional
for the criminal not mandatory I think
it should be mandatory
they can't choose a fine or community
service currently in Scotland they're
choosing a fine which they won't have to
pay back you know incrementally over
months and if they don't pay that back
eventually they could be sent to jail it
strikes me as a bit of a thing but the
experts like the Howard Lee can look at
prison reform have said this let's have
a look at this short sentences are
damaging they're damaging to the
individual concerned because they don't
help them sort out their lives they're
damaging the taxpayer because it costs a
fortune they're damaging to victims
because most people who come out of
prison particularly short sentences go
straight out and commit another crime
and they really do no good at all in
particular young teenage boys who have
committed a first offense and it's less
than 12 months and it's not violent and
it's not sexual I think you know the
kind of society I want is to see is
where they are punished through
mandatory community service which
reduces the chances of the memory
offending as well can we just get some
figures in because it obviously gives
the viewer perspective so these are
figures from the Ministry of Justice
October of last year there are around
80,000 people in prison in England and
Wales Greg as you rightly said fort in
2017 47% of offenders were given
sentences of six months or less the
reoffending rate is sixty four point
five percent for adults given custodial
sentences of less than 12 months the
reoffending rate is 38.2 percent for
adults given non custodial sentences if
you take advice from people like Bill
Bratton who was a supremely successful
police chief in both loss and in sorry
in Los Angeles Boston and New York he
goes by the broken window policy which
is if you and this so the young child a
teenager who's suddenly a shoplifter if
he doesn't the other way of looking at
it if he gets away with it a shoplifting
then he moves up the scale and the
broken windows theory says you get them
as soon as you can as I've been very
open about before when I was a teenage
girl I my boyfriend was in and out of
prison like a yo-yo that was my Saturday
weekends was going into a whole prison
to visit him and he lost been in prison
why his mates was there he had a free
gym it got all over his food cuffs he
got to watch whatever like DVDs or
whatever it was that they had in those
days and sometimes when I think back to
him I often think actually in in their
scenario there was an argument for
prisons being tougher so that when he
got sent to prison on that first time it
wasn't like you said in your
introduction we should spend more money
on prisons and if I have bigger prisons
mister you try being the prison of the
minister and getting more money out of
the Treasury for business to mom and my
my wife was a was a probation officer in
Wandsworth and you quit was very so I've
gotten quite a lot of Prisons and it's
very hard to see benefit so there I
think most of you coming back to your
point earlier most of prisons is about
you know there are some very dangerous
people we need to keep away from society
protection I'd be making prisons tougher
we've got to when we say this we've got
to understand they're currently like the
suicide rate in prisons is through the
roof the gang crime problems are it's
genuinely scary with the gang
affiliations the drug problems prison
isn't working it hasn't worked in the
United States this this no there's no
toilets policy leads to people slot
stealing a slice of pizza going down for
life in crazy stuff white choice well no
that's it things this because they
become institutionalized I wonder how
your ex-boyfriend is faring now by the
way because once you take a heart yes
[Laughter]
but before we go this is just time for
this nobody can escape the B word this
week you know to the state of being
bored as brexit drama reaches a fever
pitch it's in the news it's on every
front page it's even taking over the
pledge most everyone has an opinion on
it not everybody has strong and stable
ideas on what should be done till now
Attorney General Jeffrey Cox stood up in
Parliament to make a last-ditch attempt
to get MPs to vote for the Prime
Minister's deal this is what happened
that you are not children in the
playground you are legislators it is
your job in a minute I will I promise
the right over lady I will give way I
intend to take many interventions in the
course of this speech you we are playing
with people's lives
mister conscious attempt proved to be
useless to either main steer was voted
down in the stomach but at least he
broke through the brexit waffle for
almost a minute that's why I Geoffrey
Cox you win how straight talk and that's
it for this week you can join in the
debate online just search for the pledge
on Facebook or Twitter and thanks for
watching
[Music]